[Music]
it's been eight
months since the gang rape and killing
of a 19 year old girl in the state of
uttar pradesh
like many journalists siddhi kapan was
trying to report on the incident in the
district of hatras
when he was arrested and held in jail
accused of sedition
his family in the state of kerala say
kapan who's the general secretary of a
union of journalists
was only doing his job
it's our 19th wedding anniversary in
july i've known him for a long time now
i very well know what kind of person he
is the only mistake he made was to
travel with a member of an islamist
organization
as the uttar pradesh government faced
mountain criticism for its handling of
the case
police charged kapan and 21 others under
a law from the british colonial era
researchers say sedition is meant to be
used only against those who try to
overthrow the government by force
but there's been a reported 28 increase
in the use of the charge
every year since prime minister narendra
modi came to power in 2014.
the minister of state for home affairs
has previously said
cases under the law are not unique to
the government of narendra modi and
their numbers are low
most of those charged protesters
students academics journalists
and opposition politicians i suppose the
current government doesn't
like uh anyone disagreeing with it or
criticizing it for its measures and it
prefers to come down on that with a very
heavy
response rather than engaging in a very
you know peaceful dialogue with someone
who's criticizing them
one senior lawyer has been petitioning
the supreme court to get rid of the law
there's no justification for this law to
remain in the statute books
because incitement to violence or
incitement to public disorder
our offenses in any case under different
sections of the penal code
so this is totally redundant this law
was brought by the british government
to prevent any criticism of the british
government by the
indian subjects in that colonial times
so it has no relevance today
those campaigning against misuse of the
law were recently given some hope by
india's top court
last week the supreme court threw out a
case against a senior journalist who
criticized the government
saying disapproval doesn't amount to
sedition
the judgment is being seen as the court
pushing back against a high
number of cases being brought under that
charge
reinert says she hopes this means kapan
will be released from
jail soon elizabeth paranam al jazeera
new delhi